okay I thank you thank you very much for
having me up here I'm actually I'm very
sorry to hear talk takes place in such
circumstances but I'm still delighted
for the generosity of the donor for
making it possible for me to come here
today the the title of the talk popular
sovereignty and religious people's in
the Arab world I've tried to essentially
refer to two different kinds of
principles that would seem to be
operated almost completely in complete
contradiction to each other one is the
idea of popular sovereignty the idea
that people should be self-governing and
should make the ultimate rules about
about political life and the second
religious belief in a sense one that in
an Islamic context is often connected
with an argument for divine sovereignty
that we are believes that we're supposed
to live our lives in accordance with
god's instructions and that therefore
sovereignty properly lies with God when
you when you put it that way the two
ideas sound almost in complete
contradiction to each other well better
Minds than mine have tried to combine
them on a theoretical level I'm not
going to be talking so much on a
theoretical level today I'm going to be
talking really on a practical level I'm
going to argue that in fact the problem
in the Arab world is not how to combine
the principles in theory but an awful
lot of the problems come up in various
practical attempts to try and meet both
standards at the same same time the
problem is I've stated it would seem to
be utterly foreign to an American
audience right we live in a society that
in the u.s. you said I bring expertise
for the most exotic location washington
d.c i actually live outside the beltway
in the state of virginia i live outside
the beltway by about half a mile but i
still will talk now as a Virginian I
guess I'm not originally from there but
i but I live there now and uh and quote
the famous phrase of a Virginian over
over 200 years ago that we live in a
country in which we accept a principle
of a wall of separation between religion
and state and so the idea of trying to
incorporate an
popular sovereignty would assume you
have divine sovereignty within a
democratic system would seem to be
utterly utterly foreign an alien I'm not
quite so sure that's true today if I
look at this politics in the state of
Virginia where it happens all the time
that people make political arguments and
try to play a religious card and I'm not
even sure if it really worked that well
or completely if you look back to the
founding document so I'm going to
actually start very briefly in an
American context and use that as a way
to go into an American context and I'll
explain why I'm using that kind of odd
entry in a moment what our fundamental
declaration of sovereignty Declaration
of Independence famously precedes almost
in the manner of a Euclidean proof from
fundamentals and incontrovertible
incontrovertibly self-evident postulates
among them that all men are created and
endowed by their creator creator with
the capital C with certain inalienable
rights so we live in a country in which
divine you could you would say that the
basic declaration of sovereignty is
rooted in some kind of divine now you'll
object right away or you should object
right away that the I you know in the
18th century they used capitals letters
with greater abandoned than we do today
in our current sort of EE cummings
historical state we don't think in terms
of ultimate creators we don't think in
terms of divine origins it makes as much
sense you know to regard if you buy a
cup of coffee with a with a five-dollar
bill well it's not quite five dollars
but it will say with a cup of one dollar
bills and they say in god we trust'
viewing that as a religious Act what
would be what these words have to do is
they tell us perhaps something about our
history but in order to understand these
religious ideas in or we principles you
really have to understand how they've
lived and evolves historically and
that's exactly my point for the Arab
world that what I want to do today is to
ground our understanding of these big
ideas
of divine sovereignty of popular
sovereignty in the lived experiences of
real people's in in the Arab world and
the way that I'm going to do that is to
essentially proceed a little bit
historically over the last couple
centuries and in three stages of of I
think the struggle to sort of figure out
how to combine those two ideas the first
is exploring the relationship between
Islamic law and the rule of law leaving
sort of democracy and popular
sovereignty aside for a moment but just
trying to understand ways in which the
Islamic legal tradition could have lent
itself to a tradition of the rule of law
or whether it did that's the first
attack then the second task I will
introduce in the 20th century the
principle of the rule of the people some
kind of popular sovereignty which really
wasn't accepting their political
doctrine until the 20th century and then
in the final stage in the third part of
my talk I'm going to focus on really the
21st century when the idea of popular
sovereignty is increasingly expected to
have institutional expression in
democratic forms that we're we're
popular sovereignty is no longer
supposed to be simply a slogan so let me
first start with that first task which
really is a free 20th century the
relationship between Islamic law and the
rule of luck and they somehow be
combined when you look at it it would
seem to be anybody familiar with the
Islamic tradition of Islamic thought in
any number of realms would would see
some very easy places where you could
derive some kind of conception of the
rule of law simply because is the
community Muslim scholars have always
expressed themselves as much or is fully
in in in legal questions and legal
debates as in anything else Islamic law
get in some ways it can be kind of a
centerpiece of an Islamic intellectual
tradition so that would seem to make the
Islamic aslam as a religion is
understood by Muslims one that is very
friendly to the idea of the rule of law
idea there's some kind of Supreme Being
who is a source of law would that
encourages the idea that earthly
political authorities have to be held
accountable to some kind of higher
standards and actually if you look at
other writings on constitutionalism and
the idea of the rule of law they often
root them in traditions of natural law
of Christianity of Judaism and Islam
with its very strong legal orientation
would seem to lend itself just as easily
in some ways perhaps more so than some
other religious traditions so the
problem with trying to develop some kind
of Islamic conception of
constitutionalism of the rule of law I
don't think it's in the is in the
theoretical realm it's very much in the
practical realm the reason that Islamic
pool I think legal thought didn't really
develop fully in a constitutionalist
manner had less to do with ideas and
more in the sorts of institutions and
practices that were established in order
to pursue understand Islamic law they
was set up a claw was understood pursued
studied reproduced in a sense in a set
of institutions that were largely
distinct from the institutions of
governing in it was in the realm of
legal scholarship education courts and
and so on those kinds of arrangements
were ones which political authorities
would often show some deference to and
that they in turn would show some
deference to political authorities but
it was not necessarily a
constitutionalist now I don't want to
speak to sweepingly here of all of
Islamic history there's all kinds of
historical variation in the period
immediately before the modern era and
I'm covering the modern era essentially
as in 19th and 20th century when most of
the Arab world was governed by the
Ottoman Empire the Ottoman Empire itself
had regularizing bureaucratized a set of
religious institutions legal
institutions and educational
establishment and so on that was much
more melded into the political
structures governing political
structures that I think may have existed
in some other places so the idea of
somehow melding political authority and
Islamic legal authority was was was was
something in the sense that the that the
Ottomans had done to some extent but
what happened in the night beginning in
the 19th century was I think of
something much more extensive than even
the Ottomans had complicated in the 19th
century in a few places and then
certainly in the 20th century in most
places in me in the Arab world what
happened was it states began to infringe
on those institutions of Islamic
learning legal scholarship education
courts and not then just infringe upon
them but swallow them wholesale that is
enveloped them within the authoritative
apparatus of the states they basically
forgot that spirit of deference and
saying you know Islamic scholars are
part of a part of a set of institutions
that are somewhat separate from
governing and basically nationalize them
so and you could see that in all kinds
of of realms you know education being
primarily the the role of the state
religious institutions having been
nationalized religious endowments or
endowments for religious institutions
having been nationalized and and so
forth and so on I'll talk about this
more in in some specific institution
ways in a moment but what happened as a
result I think was that the the old
spirit of mutual deference between
religious authorities and political
authorities begin to break down and the
and it did so in a manner or without the
Islamic religious authorities having
developed any real I think extensive
sense of how to pursue and use Islamic
law in a way that would hold rulers
accountable in a modern bureaucratic
state so we come then to the the second
period of that I want to focus on in
which popular sovereignty was introduced
in essence what happened was
that as these bureaucratic states were
built they were they began to accept the
idea or be even be predicated on the
idea that they were an expression of the
will of a sovereign people if you look
for instance of the first constitutional
documented were issued governing the
Arab world some of many of them were
issued in the name of the ruler in the
late 19th century in the 20th century
they became to be issued in the name of
the people and when the people were
brought into government or it brought
into i should say issues of the creation
of the state it's not all that
surprising that they brought their
religion with them and so you have the
beginning of an attempt to define
political community in terms of both
popular sovereignty and religious
sovereignty at the same time it was one
in which was I don't think a formal
democratic process or sometimes there
were formal democratic mechanisms but
they were not they certainly were not
pluralist in nature instead I would
describe this period as broadly populous
in its approach to Islam when when when
states began to speak in the name of the
people or the claiming to speak for
sovereign people they were very
conscious at the majority of the people
that they were speaking for were Muslim
and and therefore stepped in to try and
give that some sort of expression they
did so in ways that look in comparators
a little bit odd for the most part if
what they were often interested in doing
an early period was protecting Islam
that is Islam was a religion that needed
state protection and need to state
protection from what it needed sleep
protection from missionaries it needed
state protection from
extraterritoriality the fact that
citizens of other Arabs of European
states often brought their legal status
with them when they lived in in so many
countries in the Arab world because of a
set of agreements that dated back
sometime and to some extent religion
needed protection from i would say kind
of extra
our cultural influences so you see a set
of rhetorical commitments in these
documents a religious freedom but
religious freedom essentially meaning
the state is protecting the rights of
Muslims in 222 to pursue their religion
to pass it on to their children in sort
of a communal sense there were religious
freedoms as well guaranteed to
non-muslim communities as long as they
were part of a recognized community and
as long as they didn't try to spread
their religion religious freedom on a on
a communal basis that is to say it's
much more generally a freedom to
practice religion a recognized religion
rather than a individual freedom of
conscious that's recognized in these in
constitutional documents as time went on
the populism of this period I think had
a specific and a strange kind of effect
I've called in a different context
Islamic inflation and what I mean by
Islamic inflation is this what happened
was as states increasing claim to speak
in the name of the people they wanted to
show their Islamic credentials and they
therefore the earliest constitutional
documents in the air world tended to
talk about Islam being the religion of
state of giving the protection for Islam
that I talked about but as one state
introduced a stronger clause another
state felt that it had to match it and
maybe even exceed it or sometimes a
state had to be a constitution written
in one period when a certain provision
for instance making the requirement that
the president of the head of state be a
Muslim once you put something like that
it's hard to take it out and this
process got was was steadily ratcheting
up the rhetorical commitment to to Islam
the commitments for the most part were
purely rhetorical in nature they didn't
really change the structure of the state
they didn't really change anything in
the political realm in a sense what they
were were as I said trying to sort of
attempts to speak in the people's name
and garner popular support without
making any real institutional commitment
and this is most famously seen in the
evolution of the what is still article 2
in Egypt's Constitution Article 2 in
Egypt's Constitution reads today the
principles of the Islamic sharia are the
major source of legislation the origins
of that clause go back to Syria in 1950
when I'm not quite sure but it was the
first time the narrow Constitution
really sort of as part of this popular
spirit decided that it had to have a
lengthy ideological section so they put
in all kinds of ideological provisions
and if you're going to put in everything
how can you take how can you forget God
so they put in this Islamic provision
which nobody really thought that much
about a decade later kuwait's writing a
constitution and they think well we're a
Muslim society where it's certainly
better than the Syrians and they should
they have to put in the same clause 1971
Egypt's writing a new constitution is
trying to turn us back a little bit on
socialism they put this clause in and
then in excuse me but that clause is
actually worded slightly differently
it's the principles of Islamic Shariah
shall be are a means a source of
legislation in 1980 there's a problem
for the Egyptian regime and that is that
the president of Egypt has a limit of
two terms in office and those terms are
about to expire now it was very clear to
all Egyptians that they require the
president to remain in office longer so
they had to amend their constitution in
order to meet the popular demand for
another term for president Sadat in
order to ensure that the people would
give the right answer to the question of
removing term limitations on the
president what the constitutional
amendment drafters decided to do is to
present Egyptians with a whole range of
constitutional amendments one of which
inserted the definite article V so
instead of the principles of of the
Islamic Shariah are a main source of
legislation we the principles of the
Islamic Shariah are the main source of
legislation and so Egyptians were
presented the entire concept set of
constitutional amendments as a package
and you are allowed to vote one of two
ways you could vote against the
President and against Islam or you could
vote for the president and for Islam and
unsurprisingly the present Islam won in
a landslide over ninety-nine percent of
the vote in
suggesting that Egypt's Christian
population about ten percent of the
country was just as overjoyed to be
ruled in accordance with the principles
of Islamic law as the Muslim population
with this tremendous expression of
popular well the change was made in
Egypt's Constitution that was the flavor
of the commitment the flavor of the way
in which popular sovereignty was
expressed in some kind of symbolic
religious form again however if you look
at institutional changes on the ground
you almost see things going in the
opposite direction instead of the state
and deciding to operate completely on a
religious basis what is essentially what
it essentially does during this period
is to move into the religious realm
extremely aggressively let me just give
you some examples education the
educational system education almost all
states of the action I'll stay to the
air world is compulsory at the religious
education is compulsory now what that
means is that if you want to go to a
religious school we want to go to public
school you are going to be studying
religion non-muslims of course can
usually opt out and if there's a
significant non-muslim community then
they will often have their own separate
instruction sometimes even their own
separate schools but what that means is
that if you pick up a set of school
textbooks just as there is an approved
history just as there is approved
mathematics just as there is an improved
geography there is an approved as long
the state defines Islam and has taken
upon itself the the duty of teaching it
to teaching it to children law for
instance one area of law that was
informed by Islamic legal principles
more than any others was a what's
referred to as personal status law the
term personal status law is actually not
one disbarred from Islamic jurisprudence
but what that means is when you get
married and when you get divorced and so
on in the most intimate sphere
when you are acting as a husband and a
wife for a son and daughter you are
you're legally governed by Islamic law
and States decided to decide they
decided to write down most of them not
all of them to write down exactly what
the approved interpretation of Islamic
law is that is to say they codified it
passed it by Parliament and and what
that had the effect of doing was
essentially saying there's all these
different interpretations of Islamic law
and the one that you will be governed by
is the one that we have decided is best
it goes it goes beyond this religious
broadcasting is is you're very heavy in
many many of these societies you have
essentially a private a satellite
broadcasting is relatively recent
introduction so in most of the 20th
century when you when you turn on the
radio when you turn on the television
you see any religious programming it is
going to be essentially the voice of a
state official that you're that you are
are hearing the overall effect then as
what I'm saying is was if you look at it
institutionally was not to Islam Assize
the state but you could say to stata Phi
it's not a word but if it were worried
you could say to stay defy its lob to
essentially or you could say nationalize
religion and with the result that it
sort of seemed for a while that if you
listen to public voices the voices that
could actually make themselves heard in
the public realm if you wanted to hear
the voice of the president or the king
or the voice of the people or the voice
of God they all were saying the same
thing there were a couple limitations to
this I think there were a couple ways in
which this was problematic the result
was I wish should say incomplete I'm
making it sound as if it was a
completely successful attempt but i
think it was limited in two ways the
first way in which it was limited was um
an analogy not particularly artful one
but but but I think one that
communicated very effectively when the
state decided to swallow up religion it
was a little bit like Santa Zubrus
elephant being swallowed by the boa
constrictor okay it is not it's a little
bit difficult for the state to digest
all of this and the shape in the form of
the state is very much affected by the
attempt to swallow something so large so
what the state essentially did was
twofold it was in itself all these
various different approaches arguments
and so on and so you have within the
I've got to focus here on Egypt cuz it's
a your crack apparatus is probably
studied the best all these different
agencies whose job it is to decide what
Islam is right there's a Ministry of
Education which is writing the text
books there is a Ministry of Religious
Affairs which is hiring licensing
creatures there's the misery of
communication which is deciding what to
broadcast there is a state Mufti
basically responsible for delivering
interpretations of Islamic law to say
bodies there's eleazar which is the main
seat of religious learning but also
delivers interpretations of Islamic law
and runs a huge educational apparatus on
the side of the fish'll the runs primary
and secondary schools that are that are
on religious basis so you have this huge
state apparatus developed to talk about
Islam you have a parliament that
legislating remember because of article
to that says they should they should
consult Islamic law you have a court
system that says we it is sometimes up
to us to decide which interpretation of
Islamic law should be should be binding
you have all these various parts of the
state apparatus that sometimes have
different visions and that are sometimes
trying to talk to each other and even
contesting with each other about exactly
whose interpretation is is binding whose
interpretation is valid for a long time
in Egypt the mufti the person who's
responsible for issuing religious
interpretations was a rival of the
shallows are the head of the main
religious institution in the country
they would sometimes
you dueling fat was the problem was
solved recently by basically giving the
Shaikh al-azhar some strong authority
over pointing the mufti so that doesn't
quite happen so much anymore but those
were the sorts of things that happened
it was it was a as I say a little bit
hard even for highly ambitious and
centralized state to do digest so that
was the first problem with the with the
solution that Arab states developed in
the 20th century was it trying to absorb
religion sometimes was a little bit more
difficult and a little bit less coherent
than it had hoped the second problem
with that solution is that it got old it
got old for an awful lot of the
societies that were finding ways is that
finding that the official ways in which
religion was going to be practiced
expressed and studied were insufficient
were wrong we're corrupted and so you
have the development it varies according
to the society but some places from the
50s and 60s on sometimes sometimes a
little bit earlier sometimes a little
bit later of groups and approaches and
orientations that are rooted far more in
the society than any kind of political
or official political structure there
was prominent of these of course being
the Muslim Brotherhood but it's hardly
the only one all kinds of movements some
of which have a very strong political
face like the Brotherhood some of which
have virtually no political face at all
sort of a piety movement of loosely
organized people who decide to try to
understand kind of religion on their own
they you have selfie movements which
have recently risen to great prominence
that have a sort of a distinctive
approach to religion all new forms of
religiosity that are bubbling up at the
same time as for a variety of reasons
the authoritarian Arab states of the 50s
and 60s are discovering that they've
really
reach themselves and their their their
their grip on the society they're not
becoming more democratic but their
institutional times but the grip on the
society is is is is loosening a little
bit they lose a lot of control over
broadcasting for instance as satellite
broadcasting comes in they can't stop
these signals from crossing borders they
run into fiscal crisis and therefore
literally cannot pay the salaries of all
the preachers are going to be preaching
in mosques not all the states in the
upper world how are suffering from
fiscal crisis but those that are
basically found that they were there for
losing control of the religious sector
so this kind of upsurge of popular
activism was taking place in a context
in which it was certainly not pluralist
but it was one in which the
authoritarian grip of the state seemed
to be receding and that's what I mean
when I say the the control of the state
got a little bit old for the people who
were living it that's the situation that
I think existed essentially at the
beginning of the current century of Arab
states that worse had essentially bitten
off more than they could chew if you can
remember my boa constrictor analogy and
also once in which societies were
beginning to express religiosity or
people within the societies were
beginning to press religiosity in all
kinds of different ways we then come to
the events I think of the past few years
and can understand them in and this is
the the third thing I wanted to get to
what happens when you try to introduce
actual elements of procedural democracy
into this context when the what happened
essentially in our world in 2011 was um
that once again people burst into
politics demanding not simply popular
zim populism and popular sovereignty on
a rhetorical level but they but
essentially there were widespread
demands for real democratic mechanisms
by which the people would no longer
speak in the rulers voice but in there
voice and and when the people burst in
since a lot of them were religious
they've a lot of them brought their
their religious beliefs with them we're
now three years into the aftermath of
the uprisings of of 2011 and I think
we've begun to see the deep kinds of
practical problems that have arisen as a
result of the attempt to combine to
combine now democracy with some kind of
idea of building a society on a
religious basis what I think the
practical experience the last three
years have shown is that there are two
big problems that arise in the air world
in a concrete historical context with
the effort to institutionalize some kind
of democratic procedures in this this
context the first problem is essentially
that the results are often a liberal and
the second is that the societies are
deeply divided the first problem is the
one that usually gets all the attention
but I'm actually convinced it's the less
of your problem the second one gets less
attention but i think is actually more
severe now what I mean by the results
are a liberal well um let me go back to
some things that I was trying to suggest
earlier if you have a religious Society
which is democratic what that often
means is that when you play politics a
religious card is Trump okay and that's
what happens when you play democratic
politics with a deeply religious society
and the results as I say can often be
startling illiberal its most obviously
case when it comes to cultural
production we're not going to have any
nude movies in this country okay those
sorts of things it's some it is one in
which princess Islamic personal status
law which I
made reference to earlier is very highly
gendered you bring in a gender to
Islamic personal status law with a into
the system it is very difficult to make
a strong argument or as I would say a
strong and detailed argument for gender
equality and in fact when these
countries start trying to figure out how
they're going to commit themselves to
standards of democratically gender
equality their international in nature
such as the convention economic
discrimination against women they find
out well they can't quite do so when
they ratify the convention they do so
with a reservation for that they won't
do anything that isn't consistent with
Islamic religion or Sharia law or that
sort of thing there's a matter of
religious freedom again which I alluded
to earlier the attitude towards
religious freedom I've sort of summed up
I think a little bit on charity but not
entirely inaccurately by saying the kind
of religious freedom provision that this
that this that this approach gives a
democratic approach is to say number one
there is an official religion is the
religion of the majority and the state
should support and defend it okay so
anything that is an offense to Islam
needs essentially the state to battle it
and it also means that the the on an
individual basis because you're free to
believe whatever you want but when it
comes to religious practice you have to
pick one from an approved list there is
no individual freedom of religion here
and in this sense there cannot be as
long as personal status law is primarily
religiously based right if you go into a
court on a personal status met or if you
have a personal status dispute you want
to get married you want to get divorced
inheritance dispute first question is
what's your religion and if your aunt's
that determines what
you go to or what law is applied and if
your answer is I pick a little bit of
this and a little bit of that or I'm not
really sure or I kind of made up my own
these make zero legal sense and by the
way what happens if you give that kind
of answer is you govern according to
Islamic law because it's a law of
default in most of these countries if
you don't choose one then then Islamic
law is a lot of default so there's so
what I mean by it being a liberal is
that it isn't a conception of the role
of religion and public life that is
based really more on I think communal
than individual principles I'm making it
sound perhaps a little bit more alien
than it is because when I think about
what this looks like sometimes in
practice it does remind me make this
argument before a little bit of the
America that my father was born into
which banned alcohol ban commerce on
Sundays prayer in school and it was not
an entirely ecumenical prayer and and so
forth and so on so if you think back to
a an earlier period you get some of the
flavor one in which the state I think is
a friendly force towards religion in
general but also still a little bit of
an interpreter and enforcer a defender
of religion and one in which rights
religious rights are primarily exercise
as I say on a communal rather than
individual basis so Democratic
majorities when given a voice and not
just when Islamist movements are in
power but even when non Islamist
movements are in power tend to adopt
what would seem to be a liberal
approaches so that's that's the first
problem but instance it's not it's not
it's not a structural problem there's my
reference to the Americans my father was
born in to suggest that a democracy can
certainly survive all
host of illiberal practices in the
religious realm that's why I think it's
actually the less of your problem it may
be a severe problem if you're about it
may be extremely severe problem if you
are bhai or if you're if you belong to
some sort of heterodoxy sect or if you
write novels that are considered to be
offensive to religion it would be a
problem for those sorts of people but
it's not a problem necessarily for the
political system as a whole and for its
stability in for its functioning it may
be a problem on normative grounds from a
liberal perspective but it's not
necessarily going to be undemocratic or
unstable so then we come to the second
problem about this attempt I think to
combine democracy and and kind of
religious public's I talked about 2011
as being the year the people burst in to
politics not no longer allowing a single
political party or President or some
sort of revolutionary leaders speak in
their name but demanding a direct voice
themselves and that sounds wonderful and
that sounds inspiring and to some extent
is even accurate if you go back to 2011
in specific countries when the society
seemed to rise and speak up with a
single voice the problem comes when they
keep on talking and discover that
they're actually sometimes saying
different things if they have to come up
with one word which they did in Egypt in
Tunisia some extent in a couple other
places as well in 2011 they could do so
the one word was something like go
sometimes it could extend to a short
declarative sentence the people demand
the fall of the regime ok it couldn't
get much beyond that and the the the the
the people in normal political times do
not have a single voice and they
a particularly disparate set of voices
when it comes to issues of fundamental
values and the societies and I think the
political systems were very ill equipped
to handle this and I see this for a
couple reasons or in one is actually
historical and a comparison between the
way that Democratic mechanisms were
brought in to the Arab world in the way
that they arose in say Western Europe if
you take a look and how sort of the
institutional and the legal the
juridical steps by which democracy
democratic systems were built in Western
Europe they tended to take place in
contests over two things number one the
franchise who got to vote and number two
the powers of the institution they were
voting for the Parliament okay so
democracy arose sometimes as part of a
protracted struggle over who over the
franchise and over whether the
Parliament would have oversight over the
you know whether the cabinet would be
politically responsible to the to the
Parliament whether they would have
budgetary oversight whether they could
question ministers and so forth and so
on those are the institutional questions
the interesting thing is that those were
battled out very very frankly there
weren't people who were saying you know
I believe in full democracy but there
were people who are posted amok rocee
there were political movement powerful
political movements that had some of
their questions some questions about
about about about these things um in the
Arab world by contrast universal
suffrage was one very easily and without
much contest in both places people want
to vote sure give them the right to vote
when it's first brought in their
property restrictions in some countries
and they're done away with
there's some a couple country struggles
about extending the franchise to women
but that's about it and Parliament here
they've got Parliament's they have
Parliament's that if you look at their
powers on paper that sometimes can be
actually fairly powerful they are robbed
of that influence sometimes they were
robbed historically by that influenced
by rigging elections ensuring that
there's bylaws there's only one
political party ensuring and practice
that there's going to be one dominant
party and and so forth and so on so the
struggles the institutional struggle for
democracy in a sense was one and one
easily and went early in the Arab world
and didn't mean a damn thing so that the
kinds of political struggles what I'm
calling Frank political struggles in
which concessions were one sometimes
written down in law sometimes written
down in constitutional form and and and
by and large honored had lost all of
their credibility I think in the Arab
world by the time of 2011 people had
seen elections before they'd seen
Parliament's before and there was very
little confidence that a concession that
was run out on paper would actually
translate into any new kind of practice
a very strong distrust of democratic
mechanisms for that reason so the so one
of the severe problems was simply that
that that lack of institutional trust a
second problem had to do with another
kind of legacy of authoritarianism it
was not simply distrust of formal
procedures it was inability for various
political actors to deal with each other
with an authoritarian estate that had
proved to be such a powerful presence
for so long various political actors
were even when they could articulate
their views would do so directly to the
state or to the regime or to the rule
they were not at all accustomed and had
no tools and sometimes very little venue
for dealing with each other those steps
were very rudimentary in most societies
hammering out a common platform they
could do so sometimes with vague
language but in any any sort of strong
detailed common platform was very very
difficult to arrive at and so what they
found when in a sense the some regimes
fell so easily in 2011 was that when it
came time to go beyond go or the people
want to follow the regime it was almost
as if they were having these dialogues
with each other for the first time and
the result I think has been that the
different visions of the relationship
between religion and political authority
are ones which people are not used to
having with each other ones in which
they don't trust the language that might
be drafted in constitutional legal form
to actually be honored by the other side
and so what we have is a period in which
when democracy exists when democracy is
brought in it is as I say first often
illiberal but even more what it has had
the effect of doing is exposing the deep
divisions within the society and without
offering any real tools to handle them
now constitutional democracy is a
political system that's designed
essentially precisely to do that of
getting people get getting people from
various political orientations to try
and bring their differences to the
political process and settle their
differences and decide I'm some kind of
policy outcome so it may be that my kind
of negative conclusion is just a little
bit
sure that what we're seeing right now is
a simply the first couple steps in a
direction of sort of groups that are
rendered politicizing their their their
their ideas bringing them into the
political process the translation of of
sort of active political life to stable
political institutions is one that's
very difficult and very time consuming
for all societies so it may be that the
it's the the the practical problems
which I find so severe in the Arab world
right now are just the in reality the
first steps on the road to building some
kind of political system in which those
differences are successfully managed by
the political process my own fear is
that they are steps in fact but their
steps in the wrong direction that what
they have done is is soured people on
how would many of these groups
essentially in in their faith in
politics in their faith in each other so
that the the attempt to try and bring
religious religious values into the
political realm and to combine that with
some kind of formal democratic structure
is off to such a bad start that I'm not
real optimistic about it turning around
anytime soon so I'm sorry I don't have a
happy ending a fort for the lecture but
what I would say I guess in lieu of a
happy ending is that the the the
problems as I've tried to stress are not
about any kind of inability of this
religious tradition of the Islamic
religious tradition
to handle difference to handle politics
to handle even popular sovereignty in
the abstract the problems are real and
practical in nature and they can't be
solved simply in the intellectual round
thank you goin fer ok so i should have a
question I maybe I misunderstood you so
you're saying the problem is kind of
something that's a lack of trust when
people are talking about how to buy
religion constitutional regulations so
if it is the case that people don't
think that no constitutional rules are
going to be implemented and waited you
know they're being ripped out what do
you think about why people are so
hypersensitive to like they're very
active changing the Constitution or
incorporating these things in the
constitutional law because it seems like
to me protesters realize different
different factions realize that there is
power to getting you know kind of
explicit mentions about religion into
the into constitutional regulation in
constitutional law and they want to know
they're competing of that so it seems
like they recognize there's power there
and they don't think it's trivial right
so how do you it takes me like the
problem is less a lack of trust that the
law will be implemented so much as a
fear that you know they're not going to
get the laws that they want to be
implemented
does that make any sense to you yes it
does and you may be forcing me to
reformulate my claim on the fly and it's
not going to be pretty I think there's
some truth to that at least for the last
few years or so I mean this may be an
just sort of an odd feature the last few
years when there's just been the super
concentration unconstitutional politics
the way that I would revise my statement
I mean in a sense you're right that what
people have been trying to do is to get
they that they are worried about the
results of the political process so
there were they want to get their
orientation written in as specifically
as possible into the Constitution yes
the lack of faith in is in the political
process the lack of faith is that the
political process will be one in which
they will have a voice so it may be less
of a problem of faith in constitutional
text then lack of faith in
constitutional the lack of faith in the
political process and the analogy with
19th century Europe still holds action
because a lot of these bargains that
I've talked about weren't actually
written down in constitutional form they
were ones that were informal ones that
were that were understood by all
political actors to be to be the rules
of the game only sometimes
constitutionalize much later so that's
my way of rescuing money my point yeah
glad I had two comments one was about
the comparison with America in some
degree Europe and I actually thought
that the places where you thought
America was similar with these these
uprisings or new Arabs democracies are
actually it's different and where we met
was different it actually was similar so
those two places are in religion and
politics so in religion yet if I don't
know that much but it may be true that
there were school prayers that there
were Sunday closing laws but those were
local institutions that I think we're
doing those on the state level America
you know Tocqueville comments on this in
have an official state religion which
means that the pressures that you're
talking about the fact that the
statement overwhelmed in the earlier
phases and it comes a liberal kind of
means that religion can fight it out in
civil society perhaps where the stakes
are a little less high so this people
talk all the time about the paradox of
the fact that in America is so religious
right even though we have a separation
between church and state whereas in
Europe which has a much longer history
of st. church relations they seem to be
so secular but that on the issue of
politics you know the idea that there's
a history of being able to work out
problems I guess we're talking about
this more in Europe than America but in
America in the early kind of days of the
Republic the Jeffersonians and the
Federalists were at each other's throats
with people thinking that Jefferson was
going to kind of create a revolution he
was ready to purge the Marshall court
political parties were seen as traitors
factions to be purged and so so that's
one comment and my second comment is
about I wonder if there might be a
problem of using these examples as a way
to frame it so there's been a long
history of other people's Renault much
better than I have a modernization
ideology which says things have to go in
certain steps and history I don't think
tends to repeat itself and so maybe
rather than look at America or Europe
which was had certain sets and
generalizing that as a model it's
necessary to reach a stable liberal
democracy we should look at places like
India or other places that didn't reach
it's kind of what we call healthy
democracy in the same order as as
America Europe which may not be
replicable anytime in the future
anywhere okay let me first part of the
first observation is one that I don't
have any problem with but there's an
elysian that you're making between local
government and civil society right the
you absolutely right the restrictions
were on the state are usually on the
local level but they were real and they
were using the authority of the state
because America's of federal and
decentralized system state authority
presents itself in different forms and
at different levels but it's still
fairly intrusive
so that that that's where I would push
back there on the second part of your
first observation that makes an awful
lot of sense to me and I wouldn't hold
up the American analogy that that way
the struggle was in in a sense came in
in a different form in the United States
and it did in nineteen century Europe
the second observation is actually one
that I agree with I used I i use the
analogy essentially only as a gateway to
this this argument that you really have
to look in concrete historical terms and
in a sense that's very much in the
spirit of your observation and I do that
because I think any time that you talk
especially in a general audience about I
would say about Islam in the Arab world
there is a willingness to accept a much
higher level of generalization then one
would except for a system or society
which one is more familiar with so I'm
using it as a way to say look these
things have to be have to have to be
grounded not that they're not that
there's simply one path I'm not going to
pursue the the analogy with India or try
to figure out exactly which is which is
the most case quite like the Arab world
but I would all heartily agree that
doesn't make sense to think in terms of
a unit under actual model change yeah
and back you know us ten years several
Arab states via implemented or
contemplating some key concentration of
power what were traditionally highly
centralized estates in Iran for example
year so far as recognizing a sovereign
sub-national and energy so i was
wondering how much of that debate is
happening within individual states is
there any kind of transnational
discussion about the benefits of
subsidiarity within the art world okay
and then secondly what about these
debates is old and familiar what's
really new recent development and where
is this going I'm going to inject myself
a little bit more into the sensor
there's not enough of this debate and
it's not going very well I think it's
actually an extremely important issue
and I didn't get into it because I think
it's less connected with with the realm
of religion but i think that when i was
talking about for instance the way in
which various political actors within
the society are not used to having to
deal with each other one of the reasons
for that it's a very highly
centralization of these states so is
there some discussion about it yes um
but iz iraq a model just the opposite
how did it happen okay the UN came in
and created this no-fly zone the united
states came in invaded they gave this to
the Kirk this is this is an attempt to
divide the Arab world that's how it is
understood in most kind of the Iraqi
case a successful attempt so so the
Iraqi federalism but you know and this
is a bizarre kind of federalism it isn't
necessarily working in a rocket has not
viewed it as a model in some states
there is some beginning of some
discussion about this but it doesn't end
farm what I can tell the kind of
cross-border so you know i mean the
relevant countries right now i mean you
know Libya Tunisia Egypt Yemen not so
much looking looking each other's there
would be possibilities for experiments
in decentralization the could cross
borders but I'm not aware of any of
these discussions crossing it that way
and the idea I mean the argument that I
would make is that it's important
to have I think actually to cultivate
politics at the local level if you're
going to be having a vital political
life at the national level that's not
the way the debate is usually made it's
usually made in terms of need to get
away from the center by some kind of
group that feel or region that feels
discriminate against so I don't think
the debate is going particularly well
and I don't expect most countries to get
very far unless they're ones in which
kind of the sub-national units really
have some powerful clout like in Libya
anyone doing any research on the
financing of Islamic terrorists
religious groups like for example Boko
harem or the one in a I think also maybe
Central Africa I mean it seems that the
financing you know the people who are
financing these movements seem to have
you know rather deep pockets because
these movements have gotten you know
have gotten pretty powerful and have a
lot of strength to be able to inflict a
lot of damage especially when you're
looking at you know North northern
Nigeria the other thing that I wonder is
you know one of the sources of financing
for these groups when it seems to me
that we are making Islam look worse
actual you know by their actions um
where's this let me answer your question
in a very little is there anybody who's
doing research on this and my answer is
yes in the Department of Treasury ok big
Department of Treasury oh absolutely i
mean there's a big concern with of
finance is there anybody in the academic
community who's doing it for the most
part no i mean there are a few but very
very small what's the reason this is the
sort of thing that number one it's it it
is the sort of thing that would be hard
to track number two because the
Department of Treasury is looking at it
it's very difficult to ask questions
that sound innocent on this so there
certainly are transnational networks
which move funds for charitable purposes
how much this maps on to political
activity is something I'm sure it does
to some extent but it's very very
difficult to get any kind of heart and
reliable information so it's at my own
senses it's not a place where academics
are going to make a big contribution law
enforcement officers are are are
extremely interested in this question
but I'm not even sure that they have
tools and there's as much misinformation
I think an allegation unsubstantiated
allegation in the public realm as there
is reliable information which makes it
almost impossible if anybody could say
anything intelligent about it it's not
me yeah those that seek to minimize
religion or has he tried to oppose some
of them are little as in Tunisia some of
them are not a Syria Iraq at one time
this was also the Lebanese civil war
there was a citizen movement to overhaul
this
the sectarian system there could you
comment on these on those yeah you
always have to go country by country but
in most cases they're fairly weak
political forces right for me now the
Lebanese is is as an example of this but
I'll use it just because it's so it's so
out there was certainly a movement
against sectarianism in Lebanon it was
active in the Lebanese civil war it was
led by the Progressive Socialist Party
which is usually I referred to as the
Druze party right so why the Druze
because they were a small minority and
so they were getting lost out so what
start out as non sectarianism became a
sectarian cause we are the sect against
sectarianism is what the grooves
essentially became and it basically vald
into a movement for protecting the Druze
so what happens is I think it's a
political environment that isn't very
friendly to those forces Lebanon because
of its confessional system if you start
arguing non confessional you have no
place most other countries it's not
quite that same way but if you start
making the argument of a really strong
secular argument you get almost nowhere
with and it has to do is essentially
with I think a very broad acceptance
that religious values have an important
role to play in political and public
life now so anybody who calls themselves
secularist I think it's very very
doesn't get very far people who down
play or pay lip service to religious
values they can get somewhere but
actually rip UT in them are arguing for
this for it for our separation doesn't
get you anywhere there is I think an on
trend that is now exists on an
intellectual level and I'm not sure it's
going to exist on a political level but
it to me is absolutely fascinating and I
may be reading too much into it and that
is a tendency among some that we
normally define as Islamist
intellectuals to adopt secular ideas and
what I mean but I remember talking to a
young member of the Muslim Brotherhood
this is about 10 years ago and I was
asking about the understanding of
Islamic license you know we as a
movement have to distinguish between
those
parts of Islamic law that we think the
state should enforce and those that we
just accept as teaching for ourselves as
a movement and the first should be very
very few and I'm listening this a thing
okay you're privatizing religion this is
a secular argument that's where you're
going and so I told them that and yeah
maybe so what happens when you talk to
other members of the Muslim Brotherhood
about this either we don't really talk
about ideas we're going to talk about
what we're going to do any less the
movement so in it but you will hear this
sometimes among what i would call kind
of pious intellectuals who say the big
problem of the last 20 years or so has
been this political project by islamist
movement and what is wound up doing is
bring down the wrath of the state
bringing alienating potential supporters
and concentrating so much on politics
that we forgot all the other things that
the religion is supposed to be teaching
us and so what we really need to do is
to start kind of movements that are
really much more about religion and
politics now as I say I hear this from
plenty of people i would call kind of
pious intellectuals whether it will
translate it in any kind of political
tendency or not i I doubt and certain my
sense is actually if you do have real
political democracy emerging that's the
kind of argument that's very very
difficult to make in the public realm it
just doesn't resonate Varrick very well
so i'm not sure we'll get very far but
it's an interesting intellectual trend
that i think is actually growing yeah
to get back here point about the divides
you know the divides in society in you
know I mean I've only heard people say
that that we have too many divides in
the Arab world you know we can't we're
not do modernization is not going to
work because the rectified but I guess
I'm a little you know I'm skeptical
about whether or not polarization is a
problem prior to transition or whether I
mean you know alidium is trying to get
to the more optimistic and point it said
but I'm just saying that you know it
seems that you're right about the small
franchise in Europe right that it's
begins you have a smaller group of
people within which to regulate dispute
right but it does expand rapidly right
it doesn't go continuously and so it
goes from a small franchise to a large
one I think rather quickly but then also
in other cases Latin America and
elsewhere they have the same problem of
having a large franchise at close to the
beginning of democratization and I guess
you know it seems like what democracy is
forward is a system for overcoming
divides and that system is one of
turn-taking so when people tell me we
need to be able to compromise in order
to get democracy i think well democracy
is not something you need if you can
compromise what you need it for is when
you can't compromise and you just decide
you know hey i'm just going to wait you
know to fight another day and that's the
norm i don't i worry about it i don't
know how you get that norm the one where
instead of overthrowing or see you just
wait and have your turn next time at the
polls you know the sort of the
alternation in power I'm suspicious as
suspicious as the sort of idea that you
need unity because it seems like most
people groups put forth begin any
platform had done so in the name of the
at some kind of authoritarian regime and
that the great thing about democracy is
that you don't need to have any sort of
community and certainly in the US when I
talk to people from the other political
divide I experience them is like you
know crazy idiots are insane like an
irrational way I don't I don't assume
that we're closer in our political
beliefs and two people would be or you
know let's say secularists are Islamists
in the Middle East yeah but it's
optimistic where you know i'm not sure
that divides in society are so bad for
democracy or they shouldn't be they
shouldn't theoretically be so bad um I
agree completely one hundred percent
that's exactly the problem the problem
is I mean yes if everybody agrees and
you don't need to mock receipt right
yeah even just what you get you get you
can pick pick pick leaders by law
because everybody believes the same
thing so the no I agree completely the
the problem that I was trying to point
to I what I was deliberately trying not
to make a sort of a general argument
about sequencing because i'm not sure
those get very far but i guess i got
into it a little bit with my with my
european analogy but that it's what you
don't have is a couple of number one you
don't have get any kind of agreement
about the balance of politics what is a
political matter what is it so so you
have deep divisions in this country yes
and if you factor in the Unites States
and there's also whole wide spheres you
know if you wanted nor politics in this
country you can you can just be
completely oblivious and you're fine
okay there's no there's no there's no
there's no understanding what the bounce
politics are and and people can
interpret this is vinh very personally
threatening ways they're coming into my
house they're coming into my family
they're going to attack my church
they're going to attack my mosque this
sort of thing in really personal
security terms so that's what I'm in
terms of alternation empower I think
actually that is again a part of the
problem that you don't have any
evidence that elections can be fought
what you won some mundane promise very
few Arab countries have ever had
elections twice in a row by the same
rules right so you don't have any
stability of rules and and and and the
idea that elections are ways in which
exists those those in power manufacture
their majority is very very powerful and
very very deeply rooted so I'm not sure
if that has quite the same the quite
quite the same level and to make there
may be comparable cases but I can't
think of any of the top of my head and
so and that's exactly of what has
happened I mean there are other kinds of
divisions I think that are laid on top
of this religious division laid on top
of kind of sometimes a class division
geographical division and so on so my
argument was not that the societies are
too deeply divided it's that the the
people within those divisions are not
have no tools or venues for politicizing
those in a form that would lends itself
to some kind of political process that
can make decisions and make reversible
decisions I want to impart into the room
just so you see the democratization of
long-term agrarians is led to a lot of
liberalization and we don't see that in
the Arab world seems to be correct if I
wrong the point that you're making in
this case because now we are dealing
with a deeply religious society yet you
can also make the case in this case that
you had at the beginning of
democratization in this case in Europe
be it Italy Spain or so deeply Catholic
societies in there also despite some
hiccups there in the history since you
see it Trenton deceased was
liberalisation there as well and I'm
trying this case to make maybe 11
important part of the picture in this
when you spoke a lot very lucidly about
federalization but one of the
differences there seems to be innocence
that in Europe secularization in this
case was part of democratization because
democratization business was antsy
causation together was fighting the
political power that the church actually
had at the beginning of this process the
beginning of this process was of course
before the French Revolution when we
actually seen clerics having real state
power and bishops being being princes
and all kinds of things that the Pope
himself ruler of a state so we do
actually have since medieval times in
Europe a tradition in this case where
religious authorities host a power that
seems to be lacking in this is from
Islamic history to the extent in this
case that you could say in 20's and
decreasing loss on the 21st century the
one player of power in those countries
is the state so too
exert power or to have powers and of
course there are some ways as well
through the media and support but but it
is just immense attempting to gain
powers is through the means of the state
which then also leads to religious
players in the seats as we see them for
instance on the side of the
fundamentalist video on Muslim
Brotherhood but also undecidedness is
people that are US Army more traditional
authorities in this is that that's
actually what their Tina getting moral
as a slice of the state which is
something they never had before and that
that actually leads to this different
situation and he said while we actually
see that in Europe religion was once
part of the state and that is a
situation that democratization
liberalisation cigarette addiction HD
tries to come back we see it on the
other hand in this case in lawmen
countries the other way round at the
beginning of the 20th century and also
the first half of the of the 20th
century religious authority arte powers
that's actually how they want to get
power through getting slides of the
state and in this case the process of
increasing democratization is just one
of the many means that they actually
pursue it's a fascinating comment let me
just give you three quick reactions
first you're absolutely right about the
European experience but it's a little
bit more varied I think in terms of of
you know then the way in which it led
easily to secular and and and or any
kind of secularism liberalism in
democracy right because what you're
referring to as hiccups in Spain Italy
that's fascism I mean that's that's more
than the hiccup okay I mean there are
some case Belgium is of course the case
where you had Christian Democrats in
power for a long time within a
essentially democratic political order
and you don't have you don't have the
same kind of hiccups so it's certainly
it certainly is possible and what you
see essentially is what I would argue
would be almost a slow really Christian
Democrats becoming more liberal and more
secular and the Christian and Christian
democracy right now in Western Europe
now after a century of evolution is
basically kind of Jeanette what we would
call Family Values is kind of like
generic good things for good kind of
conservative sounding things so that
would be my first comment a second
comment is the argument that you're
making the first part of the argument is
interesting because I hear it all the
time from Islamists who say essentially
all the time we don't need secularism
because we don't we never had we would
never ruled by religious authorities
this or you know Islam was born reformed
automatically we're automatically all
you know Lutheran's the this kind of
argument the second part of the argument
they don't they don't use what the part
that you're making about the about the
degree to which they want part of the
state and that's least my third comment
I mean I think you're essentially right
is that there are very few political
forces exist right now who are
uncomfortable with the idea of
significant state power in this realm
the question is who's going to use it
and how but the idea that it should be
there that the state has a role in
protecting these kind of fundamental
values that these are not personal
values but these are public values is
one that's that that's very why now
whether that has to change before you
get any kind of democracy or not I don't
know they say if I see any nibbling away
event it's at the extremes basically
from i would say people who especially
in countries where there's a strongest
Lillis movement people who are saying
you've got to get religion out of
politics as a reaction against and also
at the other extreme in essence
religious people who are
are saying when you get the state so
much heavily into religion it's it's
it's corrupting and and just let us
alone to be Muslims and you hear this
from as I say you increasingly here at
least from intellectuals who you would
normally identify this list yes
definitions of this business is
so-called much value in this case of the
Sullivans whether basic is a book no the
state is not the vehicle of this is of
creating the kind of Islam that we want
to have it is Darwin that creates the
kind of Islam that we added meaning in
this mission Priscilla tising exactly
yes so so you have i but you have sort
of a brotherhood lite version of this
argument what i would say people who who
would who early would have gravity to
the Brotherhood but you certainly have
selfies who are making you know we can
do what we want to do as long as we have
a stable political order you know a
general is just as good as an elected
president they would that's absolutely
fine to me one of the interesting
contests I don't want to get too deep
into this one of the interesting contest
I think over the the coming 10 years
there will be a contest within the
Salafi movement between those who have
been like suddenly had amazing political
doors opened up that weren't there
before and are rushing in and those who
are reacting very much against this and
I don't know which which which train
will win out yeah my question kind of
goes back to something that Adrian was
talking about I'm helping you can open
up
for some optimism here was to say that
it seemed like there was a moment in
Tunisia you know where all parties kind
of walked up to the edge of the cliff
and looked over and thought maybe it's
better not to try and push each other
off and it seems like there was this
moment where you know that they looked
in conflict could have broke it out but
it didn't and i was wondering wondering
if you disagree with that
characterization but it seems like they
sort of got themselves off the path of
violence and sort of were able to set
down some kind of bargain that seems to
be working for them better now than it
did a couple of years ago so i guess the
question is what what did they do right
and what did they do wrong and then what
are they still kind of struggling over
but first of all of my answers i think
my my neck must be constructed weird
because i was nodding I thought but if
nodding his thickness shaking my head
and then some kind of anatomical problem
so I was agreeing yeah I think I think I
mean I didn't talk about Tunisia I'm
anchored very much in Egypt as as may be
obvious to some of you but Tunisia is is
obviously a contrast and I think it's
exactly as you described it is not
necessarily the Tunisians overcame their
differences in in a way I think my
impression it is fairly superficial when
it comes to Tunisia is that they became
more aware of how much they disliked
each other as a result in the last three
years and I like to joke but it's
actually true i mean a couple times I've
been to Tunisian given given talks and I
begin to talk by saying in both towns
like was just coming from Egypt and
everything's screwed up there and you
guys are doing so well Tunisians and it
would get angry no this is awful here
don't you know what they're doing and
and so it's not any kind of grand a gram
settling differences what are the
Tunisians doing right I'm not sure that
the individual actors are necessarily
doing anything right I would point to
two things that happened in Tunisia that
that are in contrast number one there
was nobody who had abs is nobody who had
the ability to turn over the table
which it was in Egypt okay and that was
the military oh and to some extent the
security apparatus they recovered that
ability and as a result they had to deal
with each other they could not go
anywhere else in the section was second
with the election results if you're
going to do anything through the
democratic process you had to have if
you wanted to get fifty percent plus one
you had to build a coalition it was
still extremely painful and extremely
threatening and there I mean this was
not completely peaceful there was
violence and threat of violence so it's
not necessarily that the Tunisians on an
individual level did anything right but
they were they were I think we're
blessed with slightly more favorable
circumstances and my hunch is if they
could have thrown each other off the
cliff they would have and could not they
could not throw each other off the cliff
and and that and that was the the
fundamental reason and in a sense
therefore I Tunisia is an optimistic
outcome precisely because what I think
we saw when they finally adopted the
Constitution was in my mind an agreement
to say let's just start normal politics
we're not going to be able to settle all
this in constitutional form we're not
going to be able to write in everything
this get back to the earlier question
about about about these in the
Constitution we're not going to be able
to settle all political conflicts right
here right now and write everything down
let's just start going and you know with
people we don't necessarily like that
much
differences and you're thinking with
Egypt against other factors that are
making this difficult in particular as
you just mentioned the role of military
and of deep state it seems like you know
your argument about those difficulties
could apply even if religion more even
on the table more or less just looking
at any kind of post authoritarian state
as I was wondering if you could eat the
dance like kind of conceptualize that
and then also it about the role of the
development of critical parties may be
in filling this this space where a lot
of the themes you came back to or about
this kind of difficulty of talking and
spaces that are more constructive and
that often that is those spaces in kind
of normal politics of 50 large stick
with that phrase happens between within
political parties and I mean if it seems
like the new egypt that that process
never really he despite the
proliferation of parties right after the
revolution it never became the venue for
you know that coalition building didn't
incorporate the kind of dialogue we
talking about i'm wondering why that was
the case um I bet sure I understood the
first question that we did this the
second i think i understand but its
first having to do with he said
contextualizing egypt just sorry just
you know how is your story different
from a post of any forced authoritarian
state where you know you have security
services that go politicized and applies
to the ruler in a way that's
extra-constitutional you know egypt has
all of those difficulties even if they
solved the religious kind of you know
fundamental values issue wooden XLV fits
in the same sort of problems of this
trust OIC yes yeah I think they
absolutely would be they would be facing
the same kind of problems of distrust
I'm not I'm not sure how I mean there
are some distinctive features about the
about calling the deep state in Egypt I
think that are a little bit different
they're not
not they're not unique but but they cut
down on the number of comparable cases
and they're essentially the degree to
which these institutions had a great
degree in my mind of of institutional
autonomy and were able to function on
their own there are other political
systems like that but but not all
authoritarian regimes are built with I
think such a very strong sense of
institutionalization of some of the key
and an autonomy for the authoritarian
institutions but would these problems
exist without even the deep religious
divides absolutely I think it may have
been easier to craft a political
response to them kind of with a big
failure of the Egyptian revolution i
think was based on the failure of
various political and social actors to
craft any kind of program for dealing
with it or any kind of transition
essentially just signing a blank check
over the military running the transition
they signed away as possibility for it
in in terms of of your second question
that I'm sorry I again remind me it was
about a political idea I think that I
think I think I think that is actually
part of the problem I mean I wasn't
referring to it by naming political
parties ability that was to some extent
in the back of my mind when I I was I
actually interviewed some of the people
who were involved in attempts to mediate
between Morsi the Brotherhood presidency
and the opposition and it was in spring
of 2013 European diplomats American
diplomats domestic political actors what
was interesting to me was it was clear
who they were trying to it was clear who
Morsi was it was clear who the kind of
the military and security apparatus it
wasn't clear who the opposition was who
do they speak for and in essence i think
the Brotherhood made a very conscious
decision those people aren't worth
talking to they're just a bunch of
armchair intellectuals and it wasn't
clear whether the if the opposition to
come to an agreement they could have
made a stick so that was that was part
of the problem is in a sense I think the
weakness of the
part of politics how do I explain that a
lot of that has to do I think with the
legacy of authoritarianism it with the
political the political realm was a
realm of that had that was that was
futile so the only real political actors
politically viable actors with any kind
of concern eyes constituency after 2011
were those who had organized outside of
the political realm like the brother in
the selfies that was it there was a
possibility for trade union movement it
didn't arise to Indonesia you have the
trade union as a viable political actor
that made actually a big difference
another player in the game to kind of
pluralize the situation so you had and
you had no real organized constituency
for for them to draw on and the
revolutionary mobilization was so quick
and so rapidly successful that they
never built any kind of permanent
institutional structures that were that
could be in a sense proto parties so
that that was what happened and again
had you had different kind of electoral
outcomes if you'd had the Brotherhood
perform weaker and a whole host of
divided opposition but still ones in the
Brotherhood had week I think you could
have had the political space in which
those party would emerge over five to
ten years but they're not they can't
emerge overnight and that's what in a
sense what the what would have been
required for them to a form it's not
just it's not just coalition building
but it's even deal cutting they could
not even cut deals much less um
buildings with each other
you